hi so thank you guys thank you for being
here and listening to my talk if you
going to finish this so my talk is about
classifying search queries using no user
click data so we have user logs and what
I'm going to show you uses no user logs
so let me first introduce myself so I'm
currently working in the data science
team at searchmetrics I like playing
with data a lot making data-driven
studies and I like auto ammo without
looking at data or you can apply a lot
of machine learning models and come to
build like really good model without
even looking at the data and I'm very
much interested in applied ml so in this
talk we'll see how search queries can be
classified without using any user logs
or user click data and this talk is more
oriented towards applied amel rather
than mathematical formulas so don't
expect any kind of mathematics in my
talk I won't explain what neural
networks are going to details of neural
networks or Alice tiems
but rather than I will tell you how to
use them properly and I think that's
what we are looking for so let's start
with the data search metrics a company
I'm working for we have quite a lot of
data and when I say a lot of data app we
have petabytes of data like every day
and it's growing every day so with over
800 million search queries and new
queries being added every day hundreds
of thousands of new Curry's are being
added every day we need something we
need a system which classifies these
queries into categories but why why do
we need that because yeah ok my manager
came to me and told me ok classify
search queries no it's not like that so
yeah for every every day we use pythons
I could learn Kiera's which is a neural
network library for Python and extra
boost the gradient boosting library so
let's look at such query so many of you
I think you have come from
outside Berlin and yeah yeah you looked
at the weather in Germany in Berlin and
you were very happy it's 23 degrees on
the weekends is going to be 29 degrees
yeah so yeah let's search for things to
do in Berlin and then Google shows you
this okay yeah go to Brandenburg Gate go
to museum Island don't go inside Museum
and it takes a lot of time and go
checkpoint charlie or something and it
shows you a knowledge drive it gives you
okay
how much do hotels cause a three-star
Hotel or of average five-star hotel how
much do the cause you can click on the
links you can book hotels and you don't
even bother to click on the Google
search results why should you you're
getting all the information similarly
when we look for something like pirate
our child labor laws so we're looking
for pie data we get the website of pie
later we're looking for child labor laws
we get an information graph from
directly from Wikipedia and ok maybe
that's that's what you are looking for a
runt and unless you're going to details
of child labor laws so this is one more
example so I'm I'm a gadget junkie I
think many of you are so I actually
search for new gadgets online so like s7
edge so Google gives me four different I
wrote Osmonds
and then I can click on any of the link
and if I want to buy something I just
click on the link go there on the
website and buy stuff so why classify
such queries for businesses right any
business if it's a small business like a
very new startup company here which is
selling electronic stuff let's say our
furnitures are a very big company like
Amazon they all want to find out what
the user intent is when the user is
visiting their website they can log it
from Google Analytics and they know what
queries were used and how
users came to their website so they also
want to know which queries are important
for them so that they can optimize the
content accordingly but for de designers
hundreds of millions of unlabeled
keywords to play with so why not I'll do
it so when we are talking about keyword
classification we must also know what
the different classes of keywords we are
talking about so we have navigational
keywords in which the user knows where
he wants to go so if you're searching if
your search query is Amazon let's say so
you already know you want to go to
Amazon website you don't want to buy em
as long so it's like kind of a
navigational query and then we have
informational queries okay so if you're
looking for how to tie how to tie a tie
it's more of an informational query and
so it gives you a lot of information
Google has love knowledge drives that it
shows to you when you look for
informational queries then you have very
important for industries transactional
[ __ ] sorry ok thank you very much sorry
about that
okay yeah yeah for businesses then data
scientist crying guy tears of joy
so then we have transaction queries and
these queries represent intention of
buying a product or service so if you're
looking for a galaxy phone or iPhone or
whatever phone or you're looking for
shoes clothes or you're looking for a
plumber to fix something in your house
so these kind of queries are
transactional queries and so after that
you already saw that so it's no surprise
anymore is that it no it's not
so for transactional queries they can be
further divided into five molokai so I'm
explaining these categories because I
want to go deep into data and machine
learning models and before that you
should know so how many categories do we
have so we have transactional and inside
transaction we have awareness phase or
research phase user once you purchase
something then it comes in to purchase
phase or if you have an iPhone and a lot
of people want to fix their iPhone all
the time so that's the retention phase
and then we have other categories you
know like geography signs health people
a brand and millions of other categories
so where do these categories come from
they come from Wikipedia Wikipedia has
more than a million categories right now
so what was the traditional way of
classifying these queries so based on
rules everything was based on rules and
they needed user search logs so you're
looking for something and okay you
didn't like the query you didn't like
the results you come back and these
search logs are analyzed by the by these
researchers that I have mentioned here
at the bottom so you can check out those
papers it's a very nice paper and then
you have they classified into three
categories transactional navigational
and informational so if you have a query
length less than three then it's
classified navigational if it's more
than two and it's not in four it's not
transactional then it's more of an
informational query if you're looking
for a movie song then it becomes a
transactional query or image or video
collection and there are an information
queries we have questions-- words so
when did this happen
who is the President of the United
States something like this so these are
more of informational queries so now
let's look into classifying without
search logs so what do we need of course
we need the search query because we want
to classify the search query in some
category right and we need some
knowledge about the virtual work
embeddings we need info about top search
results that come with a query some
syrup integrations so syrup is search
engine result page so what kind of
integrations you see you see a knowledge
graph you see some information if you
search for Berlin you see some
information about Berlin it's the
capital of Germany or something like
this and you need some knowledge about
what unsupervised learning is some
rule-based labeling that we already saw
in the previous slide of course maybe at
some point you knew you know you need
mechanical jerks so if you labeled your
data incorrectly maybe they can fix them
for you for some money and yeah you need
to know about the machine learning
models so today I'm gonna talk about
three different machine learning models
that I used here to classify these
search queries so the first first of all
we look at the word to wake in such
worry so we all know about word two
vectors so every word can be represented
represented in multiple dimensions we
use two hundred dimensions and Germany
can be represented by a vector Berlin
can be represented by a vector so when
but you have different words and and
they are being represented by vectors if
you subtract the victor of germany from
berlin and you add france to it it's it
becomes very close to paris we all know
that we have seen these kind of slides a
million times but what happens with
search queries
so with Google now or Siri you guys are
looking for something like this so
what's the weather going to be in Berlin
or weather forecasts of Berlin and what
you get you get your weather service for
Germany you don't you didn't get things
about going to Berlin or about
Shakespeare in Berlin and I think a
Google is changing now so if you're
looking for queries like this it
understands what you're exactly looking
for and gives you appropriate results so
these are some of the real search
queries and I think these are real
search queries so viewers discretion is
advised
so you have like funny pictures and
bringing images very close to each other
then we increase and then we see like oh
yeah
Craigslist somewhere we have Google
flights so as as I keep on adding more
queries to it so Craig Craigslist forms
a cluster there so and then there is a
cluster of
dating websites here or so like Adult
Friend Finder or Ashley Madison we have
Bank of America some bank loans stuff at
the same location we have Capital One
credit card lowest credit card so these
search queries from a cluster and this
has so we took work to back
representation for each word in the
search query and normalized them
according to the number of times they
appear in the search query every word
appears in the search query and they
have been decomposed using t-sne and
represented here so there are two
approaches that we use for
classification so you have the first
approach is a combination of boosting
and convolutional neural nets which
classifies queries into navigational
informational transactional and buying
cycles the next one is Alice TMS which
are used for use to classify
words into more than 30,000 categories
so for for the first approach we need a
feature extractor of course we need a
lot of features of you want to build a
good model and you need to label the
data we need a SERP extractor so you
need the search engine result page and
for the next one
you need the Wikipedia categories
because if you want to classify
Wikipedia categories of course you
should know about Wikipedia categories
then we have like the top search results
from the google page and you calculate a
word 2x core you combine them together
or calculate a cosine similarity or
something like that then see how close
they are and then what we use is
refining of categories with knowledge
base we have in-house knowledge base and
you can listen to you can learn more
about it tomorrow and then we use lsdm
and classify in over 30,000 categories
so let's let's look at second second
pipeline first so virtual work and all
those teams we have you cannot you
cannot classify you can but it won't be
good in 1 million categories so you need
to boil down to something like ten
thousand five hundred five hundred ten
thousand and you keep on increasing and
unless you get good results and your
results don't go bad so we took like 30
thousand categories and 1 million search
queries we mapped each and every query
to a word to workspace and every
category from Wikipedia to were to x
space and then we calculate and then we
found out ok if you search for something
there are like 10 websites appearing so
we calculated were to work for each of
their titles after some cleaning so we
remove the search query from the title
and then we calculated this word to make
space for each one of them then we
extracted top categories using the
cosine similarity and uses U and we used
this label data for our other streams so
you can you can use Allah streams in a
number of ways so if
search query something like the White
House of course the won't be represented
by a word to wake but Chum just showing
it here so every word in the search
query can be represented by a vector and
these vectors form a sequence for the
sequence of sequence learning of Alice
TM and with Python it's so easy if
you're using Kara's if you know about
Kara's it's so easy you just need ten
lines of code to implement this Alice TM
and this is a very big other stream
network it takes a lot of time to train
so in the first you have you have like
three other streams here first one has
512 nodes one a twenty n nodes then
sixty-four nodes
the first two are returning sequences
the last one is not then you have a
sigmoid layer a signaler because a
keyword can belong to many categories
and when you train a network like this
we obtain some results like these for
this query so like yeah white house you
know it stays president Polynesian yeah
everyone is happy okay yeah very good
so now let's look at the performance of
the network so we see that the training
loss the training loss here is multi
class log loss it goes down and it keeps
them going down the validation accuracy
keeps on increasing from somewhere
around fifty nine percent to 62 percent
it keeps on increasing if you keep on
training for more epochs but we saw that
Ella Sims are very slow to train for one
Epoque it takes like four million
samples and one air pocket takes like
two hours train on a GPU so I think it's
better to avoid it and it was also
observed like when we are voting using a
keyword knowledge base and Wikipedia
categories we we do like two or three
voting's and we include the Wikipedia
text in that then it performs much
better than Ella streams so why waste
our time on
James and so as I said before it doesn't
so there were number of categories
before navigation transactional or
informational and still it doesn't
classify buying cycles and your user
intent and that's what we are looking
for so then we move to identifying the
user intent so let's go back to the
example we saw us at 7 edge so what do
you see you like for ads there are like
eight product placements ads so you just
go on them you click on them buy stuff
here users making them aware of the perc
it's definitely a transactional query
because it's asking you for money it's
easy to label you see these things yeah
you can label it as transactional you
then we can use the number of ads that
appear as features the number of titles
the top title search features so when I
say we are using top titles or features
means subvert direct representation of
the top titles similar example pie data
so yeah maybe you people who don't know
about by data website the Google pie
rater and this comes up now what we
don't observe is this we see there are a
lot of navigational links the user
definitely wants to go to pirate our
website he doesn't want to buy burgers
and yeah so that classifies it as a
navigational query Barack Obama we have
a Wikipedia link some news some Twitter
stuff a knowledge graph user doesn't
want to buy Barack Obama it's not
transactional query it's more of
informational he wants to know about
Barack Obama so we used all this info
for initial labeling of data as I said
hundreds of
thousands of keywords every day how
would you label them first to train a
machine learning model so a lot of
modifiers were used a lot of rules as
explained earlier and we had a lot of
other rules in that we use the search
integrations like knowledge drive for
information graph and but we we didn't
use mechanical turrets so what I think
if you use mechanical jerks the results
are gonna improve so the queries are
like navigational transactional some
navigational queries can be
transactional if you search for Samsung
maybe you want to buy a Samsung product
or you going to the Samsung website and
of course informational queries can also
be transactional and transaction queries
are then further divided into awareness
evaluation decision or retention so for
these two different types of
classification we took only the
transactional queries for sorry for the
second part we took only the
transactional queries and for the first
part which like 100,000 queries and for
the three main classes which were
already labeled according to the rules
modifiers and search integrations so if
you if you look at this graph that's if
it's visible to you guys then you can
see like apartments queries related to
apartments for McCluster
so these are virtual work embeddings
again for buying cycles since there were
four classes we took 100,000 queries
each class
next comes the interesting part using
convolution in your artworks so yeah
when it comes to convolutional neural
networks we think about dogs or cats
yeah how can we distinguish between dogs
and cats we can represent search queries
with by images so for every search
queries there exist millions of search
results or hundreds of thousands of
search results we can take every title
and convert it to warrick representation
act them together and it acts like an
abstract image for the devil
so that's Livia he won't be happy if he
sees us so then we have like image for
apple juice or Irish yeah okay but yeah
love you might think yeah it doesn't
make sense I don't see any difference
here Guild Wars or apple juice well
humans don't computers do but even
computers fail sometimes so like this
one is it a bug or a loaf of bread so
then we come to the machine learning
part of it we use two different kinds of
model to separate queries into
navigational transactional informational
and after that awareness phase the
different bind circles for different
buying cycles so for booster trees I
used word to work embeddings title from
the top results that I got additional
features from the serve pages tf-idf so
every search result was considered every
search result was considered as a
document and tf-idf was perform on it
and God bless the anchor chain for
writing XG boost it's the most awesome
gradient boosting library I've ever seen
and it takes like ten lines of code to
implement it in Python
similarly we have convolutional neural
networks so we can use images directly
feed it to the convolution network or we
can randomly crop the images so we can
take we can take a square image we can
crop them we can add them together or we
can use a lot of different pipelines I'm
not showing it here and then we can pass
it to the convolution your network so
how easy is it to implement a
convolutional neural network with curls
so here I'm showing a multi-layer
perceptron so you add a model a
sequential model then a dense layer with
400 nodes a rectified linear unit a
dropout of 15% and then you keep on
repeating or if you if you want a lot of
rays you
keep on repeating that then in the end
you have softmax or sigmoid depending on
your data if it's multi level or multi
class and similarly you can implement
convolutional neural network so here we
had we had a very huge network with so
we we had a very huge network and so
like with two convolutional layers one
activation layer between the another
activation layer dropout so I've shown
only half of the convolutional neural
network here because I don't I don't
want to discuss what exactly our network
is and then you have something like a
soft max of your so there were two
models want to distinguish between
navigational and transactional sorry one
to distinguish between navigational and
informational and another one for
transactional or not transactional so
some results a user looks for by Samsung
Galaxy and yeah of course yeah our
intuition says yeah it's a transactional
query where does it belong yeah if it's
by something galaxy the user maybe he's
gonna buy a samsung galaxy so it's more
of a decision phase similarly if you're
looking for Berlin then it's more of a
informational keyword with a location
flag in it yeah so the there's also a
location model and I didn't talk about
it
and if you're looking for Yahoo Mail you
want to go to Yahoo Mail webpage and
more like informational so ninety-eight
percent probability of it being a
navigational keyword and yeah oculus
rift
maybe you want information maybe you
want to go to the page of oculus rift
because it's rather new so yeah here
maybe you can say maybe it fails but if
if I look at it yeah it doesn't fail
that's navigational if if you search for
oculus rift on google google page you
get the navigational links you don't get
any product cards or something
and yep similarly you have iphone repair
which happens quite often it's more of a
transactional keyword or maybe you want
information about how to repair your
iPhone and it's in the retention phase
which is very difficult to distinguish
from other phases and PI data tickets
yeah you want to make a decision you
want to go to a pilot are you looking
for the ticket it's a decision buying
cycle but she had the probabilities of
the other classes are not so good here
so the conclusions I came up with a very
fast network for classifying search
queries so like more than a million
queries can be labeled every hour we
don't need any user click data we are
still doing a lot of research on it
model is improving day by day with
addition of new keywords its
outperforming the traditional methods in
terms of data in terms of accuracy and
we do have a paper in progress and you
will read more about it if you read some
papers and thank you very much
thank you as usual questions please one
hello thanks for your talk I want to ask
how do you deal with homo names yeah and
what is actually a representation of
Homo names in were to like oh there is
no special treatment so no we just Reina
what - what along the whole Wikipedia
corpus and it gives but I'm sorry if I
search for a white house but I mean
literally White House's not the White
House well any any model cannot go into
your mind and see what you're thinking
of at the time when you're looking for
such words so when you're using Allah
streams of course it can distinguish
between white house or a house white but
not these models like continents cannot
but we can distinguish them using the
search results that come up so if you're
building this convolutional neural nets
on the search results building a image
model then yeah it can distinguish just
a couple of questions regarding work to
make usage how do you model like multi
words you say you've mapped a sentence
as a query into a word to backspace the
second question is what implementation
did you use and how do you validate the
training how do you know the model with
the parameters you peek are good for
that particular scenario the parameters
for what forward to break okay so we
used in Jensen for building virtual
models and to combine like of stuff
every word can be represented as vectors
to combine these vectors together for a
sentence we are using some kind of
normalized averaging so if a word
appears two times its multiple the
vectors multiplied by two times you can
also take log averaging you can multiply
by the log of times they appear Jensen
also has an implementation
I think it's no longer experimental of
something called dr. Wecht with chicken
extension of the model yeah check it out
it helps so you you say you you're
learning these intentions without using
user click data but what you are using
in fact is the result that Google gives
which are as far as I know learned user
or built using user click data yeah but
so yeah of course
so Google modifies their search results
based on the click-through rate so if
you like the website which is that
position number 20 and if a lot of
people like it then it's going to move
up to 102 so when when I say user
clicked it I mean that okay you search
for Samsung then I your cookie has been
is being recorded by Google and it's
observing that you search for Samsung
then you search for Samsung Galaxy then
or you search for Samsung TV or
something like that so I'm not using
this data as traditional methods to UM
do you have any plan so you're only
using Google data are you do you have
any plans to try it on a different data
set or anything as in my my question is
your training the data set on the Google
results so so your training data set for
example if someone searches for Amazon
they're gonna get Amazon website not
Amazon the rain forest because Google
yeah brings up Amazon do you have any
plans to try it on a like Google has a
specific algorithm by which they give
you the results do you have any plans to
try it on a different data set which
would return more specific results sir
yeah so we are working on our different
search engines but I haven't tried it
yet and as far as Google is concerned if
you look for Apple on Google you get
Apple incorporated but if you look for
apples you get the fruit so
yeah I know it's a bit weird with Google
but we are using Google for now we still
have more time for questions
wait you're pointing to somebody sorry
hi great hug first
just one question relating changes in
Google results so what happens if you
Google changes there are top results how
often do you retrain your models well I
don't care if I have trained my model on
a million keywords or 500 million
keywords I don't care anymore
if Google changes or not but what
happens if the new keyword comes up you
tell me what happens so Google has
recently implemented something called
rankbrain
which Google is using for like 10-15
percent of search queries which are very
very new which Google even Google hasn't
seen before so we believe a ranked brain
is something like expressing two search
queries as thought vectors and word to
weight is not exactly thought vectors
and we it's just a hypothesis we cannot
replicate Google may be ranked brain is
an ensemble of neural networks we don't
know so we just keep trying and maybe we
have right now just go to work and
buildings work a lot better than
previous methods so yeah maybe we change
that in future thank you Thanks do you
detect term clusters like for example if
I say software engineering like traded
as of just one term in your vector model
because software engineers composed by
software engineering but if you see a
lot of time together probably
it means semantically yours one thing oh
yeah
so engrams right yeah so engrams are
used yeah so if software engineering
appears once so it's there is one vector
for software engineering
not one for software engineering anybody
else if this is not a case I thank you
very much I'll be sick now I got it
Thanks thank you